So looking at the text mining
problem more closely, we see that the
problem is similar to general data
mining, except that we'll be focusing
more on text data.
And we're going to have text mining
algorithms to help us to turn text data
into actionable knowledge that we can
use in (the) real world.
Especially for decision making or for
completing whatever tasks that require
text data to support, now because in
general in many real world problems of
data mining, we also tend to have
other kinds of data that are non
textual.
So a more general picture would be to
include non text data as well.
And for this reason, we might be
concerned with joint mining of text and
non text data and so in this course
we're going to focus more on text
mining.
But we can also touch how to join the
analysis of both text data and non-text
data. With this problem definition we
can now look at the landscape of the
topics in text mining analytics.
Now this slide shows the process of
generating text data in more detail.
Most specifically, human sensor or
human observer would look at the world
from some perspective.
Different people would be looking at
the world from different angles and
they will pay attention to different
things.
The same person at a different time might
also pay attention to different aspects
of the observed world.
And so the human sensor would perceive
the world from some perspective.
And that human...
The sensor would then form a view of
the world and that can be called the
observed
world.
Of course this would be different from
the real world because of the
perspective that the person has taken.
This can often be biased also.
Now the observable world can be
represented as for example entity
relation graphs or more in a more
general way, using knowledge
representation language.
But in general, this is basically what
a person has in mind about the world,
and we don't really know what exactly
it looks like, of course.
But then the human would express what
the person has observed using a natural
language such as English, and the
result is text data.
Of course, the person could have used a
different language to express what he
or she has observed.
In that case, we might have text data
of mixed languages for different
languages.
So the main goal of text mining is
actually to revert this process of
generating test data.
And we hope to be able to uncover some
aspect in this process.
And so specifically we can think about
the mining, for example, knowledge
about the language.
And that means by looking at text
data in English, we may be able to
discover something about English...
Some usage of English...
Some patterns of English.
So this is 1 type of mining problems
where the result is some knowledge
about language which may be useful
in various ways.
If you look at the picture, we can also
then mine knowledge about the "Observed
World".
As so, this has much to do with mining
the content of text data.
We're going to look at the what the
text data are about and then try to get
the essence of it.
Or extracting high quality information
about a particular aspect of the world
that we're interested in.
For example, everything that has been
said about a particular person or
particular entity, and this can be
regarded as mining content to describe
the observed world in the user's mind,
in the person's mind.
If you look further then you can also
imagine we can mine knowledge about
this observer himself or herself.
So this has also to do with using text
data to infer some properties of
this person.
And these properties could include the
mood of the person or sentiment of the
person.
And note that we distinguish the
observed the world from the person
because text data can describe what
the person has observed in an
objective way, but the description can
be also subject with sentiment, and so
in general you can imagine the text
data would contain some factual
descriptions of the world plus some
subjective comments, so that's why it's
also possible to do text mining to mine
knowledge
about the observer.
Finally, if you look at the picture to
the left side of this picture, then you
can see we can certainly also say
something about the real world, right?
So indeed we can do text mining to
infer other real world variables, and
this is often called predictive
analytics.
And we want to predict the value of
certain interesting variables.
So this picture basically covered
multiple types of knowledge that we can
mine from text in general.
When we infer other real world
variables, we could also use some of
the results from mining text data as
intermediate results to help the
prediction.
For example, after we mine the content
of text data, we might generate some
summary of content, and that summary
could be then used to help us predict
the variables of
the real world.
Now of course, this is still generated
from the original text data, but I want
to emphasize here that often the
processing of text data to generate
some features that can help
with the prediction, is very important.
And that's why here we show that the
results of some other mining tasks,
including mining the content of text
data and mining knowledge above the
observer can all be very helpful for
prediction.
In fact, when we have a non-text data,
we could also use the non-text data to
help prediction.
And of course, it depends on the
problem.
In general, non-text data can be
very important for such prediction
tasks.
For example, if you want to predict the
stocks.
Stock prices or changes of stock prices
based on discussion in the news
articles or in social media, then this
is an example of using text data to
predict some other real world
variables.
Now in this case, obviously the
historical stock price data would be
very important for this prediction, and
so that's example of non-text data that
would be
very useful for the prediction and we
can combine both kinds of data to make
the prediction.
Now non-text data can be also
useful for analyzing text by supplying
context.
When we look at the text data alone
will be mostly looking at the content
and opinions expressed in text.
But text data generally have also
context associated.
For example, the time, the location,
of that associated with the text data
and these are useful context
information.
And the context can provide
interesting angles for analyzing text
data.
For example, we might partition text
data into different time periods
because of the availability of time.
Now we can analyze text data in each
time period and then make a comparison.
Similarly, we can partition text data
based on locations or any metadata that's
associated
to form interesting comparison
scenarios.
So in this sense, non-text data can
actually provide interesting angles or
perspectives for text analysis, and
can help us make context sensitive
analysis of content or the language
usage or the
opinions about the observer or the
authors of text data.
We could analyze the sentiment
in different context, so this is fairly
general landscape of the topics in text
mining and analytics.
In this course we're going to
selectively cover some of those topics.
We actually hope to cover most of
these general topics.
First, we are going to cover natural language
processing very briefly because
this has to do with understanding text
data, and this determines how we can
represent text for text mining.
Second, we're going to talk about how
to mine word associations from text
data and word associations is a form of
useful lexical knowledge about a
language.
Third, we're going to talk about the
topic mining
and analysis, and this is only one way
to analyze content of text, but it's a
very useful way of analyzing content.
It's also one of the most useful
techniques in text mining.
And then we're going to talk about
opinion mining and sentiment analysis.
So this can be regarded as one example
of mining knowledge about the observer.
And finally, we are going to cover a text
based prediction problems where we try
to predict some real world variable
based on text data.
So this slide also serves as a road map
for this course.
And will use this as outline for the
topics that will cover in the rest of
this course.